[Musique]
mecheri
un patois pour les cannois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez rendez vous avec une meuf mine
de rien il faut voir comment elle arrive
bah oui si elle arrive frère à l'arrivée
de jolis avec des chaussures à la houle
à sweat à capuche et un peu dégueulasse
annoncé que non alors tu sais que c'est
sûr et certain que tu la pêche aura pas
c'est que deuxième truc quand vous
ramener la meuf à la maison si elle
commence à chercher ses clés
cinq minutes avant nous arriver c'est
pas bon pas bon du tout ça veut dire
qu'ado vite ce baryton connais les mecs
vous lire droite merci aux maximes
canigou revenez demain si vous le
souhaitez non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'honneur de m'adresser à bout ce
soir le plus sobrement possible afin de
vous souhaiter tous mes voeux pour cette
nouvelle année
j'en profite également pour vous
annoncer que tpm paix devient une
émission plus sérieuse que culturel qui
sera au coeur de l'actualité
[Musique]
alors max elisany qui fera ses scoops de
matching annie à sa place parce que hier
je vous raconte tout va chauffer les
petits débris démission hier il m'a dit
c'était froid quand je me déplace ou que
c'était le plateau n'était pas chaud
mais quand je suis arrivé ici je sentais
gamme et du froid
je parvins à mettre la table pour faire
ma chronique a fait un truc à tes
cheveux j'ai vu là après filet mais si
c'est un peu long là tu as fait un truc
après les films équipe aura course je
sais ça c'est le coiffeur à la fin des
normalement sa part normal je suis comme
un asthme chez le coiffeur je connais je
voudrais bien moi je vais faire un peu
de bleu royal au pas peur il prend ainsi
nous fait tout ça est fait ce geste là
je connais je connais pendant les
vacances je suis allé aux 78 je suis
allé aux états unis je suis à la new
york
on n'était qu'un pote jean rachid n'a
mis que vous connaissez donc on arrive
hélas la deuxième qu'il faut l'est de la
france
iam jimmy fallon l'imf rennes jimmy
fallon est l'hôte et google lysozyme on
est resté deux heures avec le gars il
dit pourquoi vous êtes là qu'est ce que
vous avez fait pourquoi vous allez venir
pourquoi nous avons là après il nous
laisse partir là on fait 50 mètres et un
autre gars qui fait là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils fouillent naussac savez je suis fan
de crimes de crimes de trucs comme ça
détective et j'ai acheté deux revues une
revue d'effectif et nous serions déjà
marqué en et non criminelle et il
appelle et live comme ça ils appellent
polaire et donc idylle prend mon
passeport et on va google ici
ouais c'est vrai toit way away est donc
là les gars super sympathique
du coup on a pris un petit verre avec le
sourire et corinne après mon des tubes
you come back when you le 30 mars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
raymond sont prêtés dans ce moment je
suis un leader quoi certains leaders
d'opinion soient absolument je suis un
leader et ce leader dans la vie scheider
à l'antenne je suis un leader au leader
lotois leader price dans l'émission ce
soir sur les pouvoirs du corps humain et
disent que les sommes qu'on la barbe
sont plus recherchés par les femmes ils
sont est dans l'émission et que quand on
commence à rencontrer une fille et ben
les poils de la bat pour davantage parce
que c'est le taux doit vous voulez pas
les voir tout ce que j'ai envie de faire
quand j'écoute cette mini j'ai envie de
dire à matthieu delormeau bien ou part
en voiture c'est vrai cette musique à
fond à l'onf et paris toulouse ensemble
comme ça pas la seule chose c'est
oublier préciser c'est que je te laisse
au premier péage
[Musique]